[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
dimanche en politique sur france 3
bourgogne les français ont de moins en
moins confiance dans leurs élus en
particulier à l'échelon national cette
rupture est elle définitive la question
mérite d'être posée au moment où la
mobilisation des gilet jaune la faire
ressurgir de façon urgente pourquoi une
telle défiance les citoyens et les
politiques sont-ils réconciliables
comment associer les français aux
décisions prises en haut lieu on en
débat avec nos invités ce dimanche matin
en direct didier parisse bonjour bonjour
vous êtes député la république en marche
de côte-d'or et bien sûr comme à tous
nos invités je vais vous demander
d'abord et avant tout de réagir aux
événements d'hier il y a eu des
manifestations de gilet jaune un peu
partout en france celle des champs
elysées a très mal tourné on va en voir
quelques images
a dijon il ya eu aussi des difficultés
de ce côté là est ce que le gouvernement
votre gouvernement le gouvernement que
vous soutenez n'a agi correctement
reste une question d'ordre public à mon
sens oui il faut entendre le
mécontentement
même si il ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
sont sans doute le fruit de d'années et
d'années de dynaction politique il faut
aussi ne pas accepter les débordements
auxquels on a assisté sans 33 blessés
c'est impossible c'est inconcevable mais
pour vous le gouvernement a bien géré la
question de l'ordre public sur
franchement on a on a deux choses et
j'ai une manifestation qui est
parfaitement légitime c'est notre
constitution
manifestons et des casseurs qui ne
viennent du que dans cet esprit paillage
au filtrage en a pas suffi
vous voyez à quel point c'est difficile
de contenir ces quelques milliers de
personnes qui ne cherchent qu'une chose
s'est cassé
je note une diminution du nombre de
gilet jaune manifestants de semaine en
semaine et une radicalisation une
violence qui qui qu'on a vu hier
franchement mettre le feu à un bâtiment
sur la place de l'étoile dégradé
tous les lieux publics alors et aller
taguer l'arc de triomphe franchement je
ne suis pas fier de cette image en voit
aussi la des images à dijon hier soir et
ce matin jean bernard laville bonjour je
vous êtes retraité c'est votre état
actuel vous êtes membre d'un gilet jaune
en saône et loire vous êtes mobilisés
depuis le début de ce mouvement
comment est ce que vous avez réagi à ce
que vous avez pu voir en images hier ben
je vous dirais franchement j'ai plutôt
lu ce matin parce qu'ils y ajoutait au
fond du manie avec des gilets jaunes
oui deux locaux seront sur les mines
près de montceau les mines le bon j'ai
vu quand même les images
ce matin je peux vous dire que personne
ne se réjouit en tout cas moi je parle
au nom des gens que je connais honeywell
ou mini c'est que personne ne se réjouit
de ces violences sauf que on à monsieur
paris s'est dit que y voit de moins en
moins de vrais gilet jaune nous ou
manille on est de plus en plus nombreux
et la question de savoir si on serait là
aujourd'hui ne s'est même pas posée
cirque a pas eu débat c'était implicite
on a déjà les sapins pour noël ce que je
veux dire c'est que certains ont brûlé
hier dans les rues de dijon
oui mais pas chez nous autour mais moi
je peux pas parler de choses que je ne
connais pas reçu ce bébé mais est ce que
vous vous désolidariser de deux de ses
actions qu'on a vu hier est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui vous choque
le mot de sa question c'était ça le mode
et se désolidariser c'est ça facile
voilà il vous ça implique que hausserait
ou koné était à un moment solidaire on
n'a jamais été solidaires de ces
mouvements là c'est pas ma vision du
mouvement moi de ce que des gens que je
connais je peux vous dire que non
absolument pas merci on va y revenir
évidemment sandrine healy bonjour vous
êtes conseillère départementale de
côte-d'or conseillère municipale de
dijon membre d'europe écologie les verts
vous êtes notamment spécialiste de
démocratie participative toutes ces
questions vous intéresse beaucoup on va
y venir dans un instant mais mais
d'abord pour vous d'où vient le problème
est ce que il hier ce qui s'est passé on
aurait pu être évité est ce que ça
aurait pu être évité
je pense qu'on est arrivé à un degré
d'accumulation de colère et de
souffrance des gens est donc c'est pour
ça qu'il ya eu une multiplication des
des manifestations sur trois samedis et
on est touché au coeur par cette
souffrance des gilet jaune ca c'est
indéniable elle est cette souffrance est
l'expression d'une blessure une
accumulation depuis 40 ans au final où
il ya eu beaucoup d'alternance entre la
gauche la droite on a même essayé la
cobi cohabitation parfois il y avait un
président de gauche avec un gouvernement
de droite
avec on a essayé un président de droite
avec un gouvernement de gauche parfois
j'ai effectivement et on a participé sur
la démocratie participative on à
dominique voynet par exemple en 99 dans
les territoires avec la loi va one est
la démocratie participative on a
toujours essayé de mettre en avant tout
ça et je pense qu'il faut faire la
distinction
françois rebsamen a condamné avec force
ce qui s'est passé à dijon c'est à dire
de détruire de brûler les voitures et
caetera et les gilet jaune ne sont pas
pour ça mais on comprend cette
souffrance et on arrive et surtout en
discuter avec monsieur nabil en arrivant
il est absolument incroyable de penser
que les jets les jeunes sont contre
l'écologie c'est ça aussi qu'il faut
absolument revenir la question de
qualité voilà ça a été une goutte d'eau
mais ça a été une accumulation le
problème si c'est que le président
emmanuel macron n'avait pas comme les
autres présidents 40 ans de terrain
derrière lui quand vous avez du terrain
si vous passez de hauts fonctionnaires à
l'entreprise privée à la politique sans
avoir fait du terrain pendant 40 ans en
rencontrant les personnes dans les
associations les manifestations vous ne
pouvez plus avoir de contacts directs et
de communication directe on est sur des
problèmes de communication et des
problèmes de fin de mois on en discute
et tout allait remplir le frigo on va y
revenir bien sûr leur l'instant je viens
ou double
vous êtes vous conseiller régional
rassemblement national président du
groupe fn au conseil régional bourgogne
franche comté alors la question où
l'attendait sans doute
marine le pen a invité les gens à se
rassembler sur les champs elysées avant
cette manifestation est ce qu'elle a
bien fait ou est ce qu'elle a jeté de
l'huile sur le feu la question n'est pas
là la question c'est que nous avons tous
été choqués par les événements d'hier
par la brutalité et moi je suis choquée
d'abord d'avoir un président de la
république qui attise la guerre civile
par une attitude totalement
irresponsable
clairement quand on a un président de la
république qui est à ce point étranger à
son propre pays qui est à ce point
indifférent aux souffrances de son
propre peuple
ça entraîne ce genre de situation et ça
entraîne sous climat de guerre civile
puisque encore une fois le mouvement de
gilet jaune est l'expression de la
souffrance du peuple français qui est en
train de crever de faim mais vous pensez
pas qu'on peut jeter de l'huile sur le
feu en appelant à aller sur un lieu de
manifestation qui n'est pas autorisé
parler du tout à l'arrivée de la cité
d'ailleurs vous allez remarquer qu' hier
elle a tout de suite
inciter les gilet jaune à se disperser
pour ne pas justement être entraînée par
les casseurs car une fois encore une
fois le gouvernement des macros et le
miz d'intérieur christophe castaner sont
responsables son responsable parce
qu'ils n'ont pas mis encore une fois les
mesures nécessaires pour neutraliser les
casseurs et on le sait pour les milices
d'extrême gauche les mêmes blacks blocks
qui me lisent extrême droite aussi
d'ultra lagrasse même impact
non non ça n'a pas été prouvée
d'ailleurs à chaque fois que vous avez
des individus interpellés ne sont pas
des mouvements ultra droite et les tags
qu'on a pu voir qui ont souillé et ça a
été quand même extrêmement choquant
l'arc de triomphe était ultra gauche
d'extrême gauche vous avez le à
d'anarchistes vous aviez même des tags
communautariste puisqu'il y avait un
soutien à damas et s'est donc il n'y a
rien à voir il faut pas instrumentaliser
donc cette cette colère alors jean
bernard laville je vous pose une autre
question sur ce mouvement et puis on va
en revenir à notre débat du jouet mais
est-ce que vous
vous pensez qu'il faut continuer comme
ça certains appellent à un nouveau
rassemblement samedi prochain un peu
partout en france et notamment un grand
rassemblement à paris aujourd'hui dans
une tribune dans le journal du dimanche
on est en direct
on en profite dès gilet jaune qui se
déclare libre à eux appellent à un
mouvement constructif
en essayant de dialoguer qu'est ce que
vous en pensez et est-ce qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une décision tout de suite
du gouvernement laquelle voici à une
décision tout de suite du gouvernement à
prendre
c'est tout de suite de deux voire
l'achat pour des gens qui travaillent
qui dans leur voiture pour des gens qui
a au 10 du mois commence à avoir des
difficultés pour se nourrir
voilà ça c'est l'urgence l'urgence
ultime
alors je suis d'accord avec le plus
important là en ce qui me concerne les
gilets jaunes ils se sont bien
conscients de ça c'est le plus important
c'est l'écologie aussi parce que ça sert
à rien d'avoir une justice sociale
donc si on veut du site social il faut
une justice fiscale
ce qui n'est absolument pas le cas
actuellement et ensuite
même si tout allait parfaitement bien
ensuite si on peut pas respirer ça sert
à rien on est bien d'accord
alors didier marché je voudrais terminer
je voulais dire simplement que votre
vote réponses sont très politiques moi
je pense qu'on n'est pas là pour ça vous
allez là pour avancer pour trouver la
vraie solitude réponse s'avère une autre
occasion qu'il est il n'est pas là nous
ici on n'est pas là pas à s'excuser moi
je suis élu fait république va donc
c'est aussi dans mon rôle et les
décisions politiques qui sont prises par
ce gouvernement prenne une macro sont
responsables de la colère du peuple
français et son responsable de la sfi
psy fiscale alors didier parisse hier
françois rebsamen le maire de dijon
appelait le gouvernement à renoncer à
faire payer aux plus modestes les taxes
sur l'énergie aie demandé le
rétablissement d'un impôt de solidarité
écologique pour les plus riches
est ce que c'est la première décision à
prendre pour que cette histoire s'arrête
et qu'on évite l'escaladent ce que je
veux dire c'est que il ya sans doute des
décisions immédiates à prendre moi hier
j'ai passé la journée à rencontrer des
gilet jaune comme beaucoup de députés à
la mise en marche et amaigri
comme tout est vu du concentré de votre
question c'est le lien entre les élus et
le peuple c'est notre job on le fait il
n'y a aucun souci
j'ai rencontré des gilets jaunes dans
des conditions tout à fait
satisfaisantes de bons débats de de bons
dialogues
ce que je remarque quand même c'est que
le volume des revendications extrêmement
large
il va dans tous les sens et que j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal je vous le dis j'ai
beaucoup de mal à rencontrer des
personnes qui a accepté de porter une
parole pour d'autres c'est une
difficulté que nous rencontrons à un
mouvement dont on peut parfaitement
comprendre l'origine diffuse mais
maintenant on est à un stade où il faut
que ça soit moins diffus que ça donc
chercher des porte parole voilà nous
avons besoin de porte paroles nous avons
besoin de ré instaurer un dialogue qui
est absolument fondamentale nécessaire
nous sommes dans une démocratie elle ne
peut exister sans dialogue donc nous
cherchons les voies et les moyens de
reconstruire ce dialogue
après franchement faire ce que dire ce
que j'ai entendu sur l'origine d'un
mouvement encore une fois ça fait
longtemps longtemps que les français
souffrent pour certains d'entre eux il
ya aucun doute même si les chiffres ne
leur donne pas forcément raison mais le
sentiment que les français peuvent avoir
c'est un sentiment de décrochage de
souffrance je n'ai pas interrompu moi
c'est pas mon habitude c'est un
sentiment de décrochage de souffrance il
faut y répondre
je crois que physiquement il ya une ou
deux mesures importantes qui pourraient
aujourd'hui être prises et si vous vous
dites qu'il faut ça y est il faut lâcher
du lest sur ces questions de carburant
par exemple est ce que vous faites
partie des députés la république en
marche qui disent je vais là il faut
peut-être que je fais partie des députés
qui pense que nous avons un travail à
poursuivre
ça fait trop longtemps qu'on fait rien
pour se satisfaire de l'inaction qui se
poursuivrait donc un travail fondamental
à poursuivre la restauration du de la
place du travail dans notre société qui
était trop largement oublié le goût de
l'effort mais aussi la solidarité à
laquelle nous sommes tous attachés
wiesen la suppression ya savent c'est à
dire avant première à votre question me
renvoie sur une autre question pour moi
il me semble que il ya peut-être de
chose à faire aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement je suis pas sûr qu'il
faille pas rediscuter sur la vitesse à
laquelle les
les réformes s'enclenche et en
particulier celle de ma nouvelle
augmentation des taxes sur les
carburants
mais je pense ça pourrait être une
discussion qui doit être menée et la
deuxième c'est le smic
ça fait six ans qu'on n'a pas eu
d'augmentation du smic patron de or
voilà aucun coup de pouce en tant que
député responsable de la république en
main je me pose la question
oui il faut qu'on ait cette discussion
elle est complexe parce qu'elles
renvoient la responsabilité aussi au
monde de l'entreprise qui aussi a ses
difficultés mais qui peut prendre part à
cette évolution
sandrine et les volets réagi ensuite
julien au double des réponses cours
parce qu'on voudrait revenir sur les
porte paroles en fait je pense que vous
ne comprenez pas bien ce mouvement
citoyen qui est plutôt horizontale et
lui de gros a chuté
oui bien sûr mais vous ne pouvez pas
leur demander d' absolument fléché des
porte parole parce que il ne fonctionne
pas sur du vertical et une de fonctionne
sur un système horizontale mais il
saint-omer alors il saint-omer avait
étudié mouvement nuit debout et avait
remarqué effectivement que ça se
recroisent aussi avec les réseaux
sociaux on retrouve des noeuds c'est à
dire malgré tout des personnes qui sont
en compte axer ses huit personnes qui
avaient été identifiés mais les les
personnes ne veulent pas d'une porte
parole c'est pas forcément la notion de
chef
voilà oui mais ils veulent en garder cet
aspect horizontal et à ce moment là
c'est toute la difficulté d'arriver
effectivement à rentrer dans un dialogue
mais à partir du moment où vous
réfléchissez avec les schémas de
l'ancien monde vous ne pouvez pas
comprendre ce mouvement citoyen julien
houle et puis jean bernard à la ville
sur cette question oui monsieur pâris
comme ses collègues la république en
marche n'ont pas compris et ne veulent
pas finalement entendre on avait avant
le sentiment d'insécurité
on a maintenant le sentiment de pauvreté
sous-entendu que le pouvoir d'achat va
mieux
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
chiffres de ligne ou me décider mais je
prenne en compte des critères très large
et français ne le voit dans les
quotidiens voient pas excusez moi je
prends un exemple dans mon département
de l'yonne à sens g nathalie qui
travaille dans une société de services à
la personne
elle touche 850 euros
moi depuis les os donc du prix de
l'essence c'est 400 euros par mois pour
les carburants pour tous ses
déplacements
voilà comment elle fait pour vivre c'est
ça la question et aujourd'hui vous avez
des français et surtout de nos
départements ruraux de la france ou des
oubliés la france rurale périphériques
qui ne peuvent plus le cache du mois
qu'ils n'ont plus d'argent qu'ils n'ont
plus d'argent qu'ils font qui des
arbitrages sur leur chauffage qui font
les arbitrages sur leur qualité de vie
qu'il faut leur avantage sur leurs
déplacements donc ils sont finalement à
signaler ça fait longtemps que ça dure
ça fait longtemps mais là aujourd'hui le
mouvement de fond qui se passe
actuellement c'est la révolte du peuple
majoritaire du peuple centrale et c'est
ce qu'ils n'ont pas compris
voilà c'est qu emmanuel macron est le
président d'une autorité et abandonner
le peuple 103 bien en a marre de payer
pour qu'ils menacent et or n ayez envie
de rejouer les prisons ciel libyen le
front national parce que pour moi ya pas
de rassemblement national à tracer de
nouveaux noms vous avez mis en marche
on a accepté de changer le nom aussi
parce que c'était moi qui venge moi je
pourrais pas partir dont vous ai demandé
comment est-ce qu'on peut s'en sortir de
ça je vous dis rien à q n'y a qu'une
seule solution c'est d'arrêter de que
justement c'est la justice comme quoi
y'a des gens qui travaillent et puis qui
demande en voitures etc etc
mais moi je voulais me faire voir vous
parlez de de pouvoir d'achat nous faire
voir ça c'est du café et des notes de
café alors entre le février 2015
oui coûtait 0 78 c'est pas le café que
vous achetez ces cafés top budget d'une
enseigne d'une grande enseigne et
janvier 2018
il est à 1 22 il augmente et donc de
zeeuw 56 oui c'est 56 41 % en trois ans
bon je pense j'ai pas fait le calcul
c'est que le café autour de 15
ce qui est important c'est que ça capte
café top budget les gens au lieu de leur
donner du pouvoir d'achat qu'est ce
qu'on fait on dégrade on augmente parce
que non le café normal peu plus de payer
les gens veulent pas le payer plus cher
alors on augmente le café top budget de
4,5 pour cent et les jets les facs pas
le gouvernement qui augmente le prix du
café on est d'accord mais non mais
comment je fais pour compenser cette
situation là je crois que vous avez
raison nous avons nous avons en france
une population et compris salariés qu'on
appelle des salariés pauvres etc
le vrai problème que nous rencontrons il
est là c'est la raison pour laquelle l
hommage c'est la raison pour laquelle
chômage sévit ces raisons c'est aussi
une autre difficulté à laquelle il faut
s'atteler et c'est ce que nous essayons
de faire sur les salariés par exemple
est-ce que vous rappeler que depuis deux
mois les salaires ne pète pas le
quotidien ne paye plus de cotisations
sur l'assurance chômage
c'est pour ça qu'il ya d'assurer sur
maladie pour ça qu est ce que vous vous
rendrez mais en à la sarre et bien que
la csg a augmenté et c'est vrai
notamment melero de la csg à augmenter
pour tout le monde y compris pour les
revenus des capitaux c'était le but
on s'était le but pour permettre d'avoir
la politique sociale que nous mettons en
place il faut aussi avoir les moyens de
la mettrons dans là quand même
l'impression donc il y à une
incompréhension qui s'est creusé en
vivre les citoyens et les politiques
notamment les politiques à l'échelon
national parce que vous le rappeliez
indiqué parisse mais les élus locaux
sont son taux sont fréquemment au
contact des citoyens je vous propose
d'entendre les propos du président de la
république emmanuel macron le 14
novembre dernier en pleine mer sur le
charles de gaulle c'était chez nos
confrères de tf1 regardez cet extrait
est ce que je considère qu'il ya une
erreur stratégique a été faite par le
gouvernement
non est ce que je veux changer la ligne
non est-ce que je pense qu'il ya une
erreur de fond non quelque chose que je
n'ai pas vraiment réussi à faire
c'est je n'ai pas réussi à réconcilier
le peuple français avec ses dirigeants
et ça c'est vrai
et ça me touche moi mais si ça me touche
et que ma personne à la rigueur ce ne
serait pas grave
mais c'est plus profond et ce divorce on
le voit dans toutes les démocraties
occidentales
emmanuel macron chez nos confrères de
tf1 le 14 novembre avant le premier
rassemblement du 17 novembre des gilet
jaune didier parisse
c'est presque la première fois qu'on
entend un aveu d'impuissance ou un aveu
d'échec du président emmanuel macron qui
d'habitude est plutôt droit dans ses
bottes et c'est vraiment je crois qu'il
eut raison de le dire il ya un problème
fondamental
il a sans doute plusieurs origines des
origines c'est que nous avons nous
sommes partis de l'idée que la france
était dans un tel état par l'inertie de
tous les gouvernements précédents qu'il
fallait agir et qu'il fallait agir vite
je me demande si on n'agit pas un peu
vite au point où effectivement une
partie des français qui décroche parce
qu'il nous ils n'ont pas le temps
d'assimiler ils n'ont pas le temps de
comprendre moi ce que je dis c'est pour
ça que tout à l'heure vous avez dit il
faut peut-être ralentir légèrement le
rythme est ce que j'espère c'est d'ici
un an deux ans trois ans l'état de la
france sera différent de celui dans
lequel nous l'avons trouvé il ya un an
et demi c'est ça mon espoir et c'est une
des raisons qui fait qu'ils font que je
pense qu'on on saura renouer ce dialogue
pour autant pour autant et vous avez
raison je me tourner vers ma d'amélie il
ya sans doute aussi des nouveaux modes
de fonctionnement a inventé moi je crois
que là ce qui vient de se passer est
suffisamment grave pour que nous en
tirions des conséquences notamment dans
des cas passés dialogue plus local tout
ne peut pas venir du rouillât aucun
doute
inventons les dialogues je parle bien du
mot de dialogue je parle pas du mot de
front inventons des dialogues qui
convienne et écoutons les français qui
doivent eux aussi eu mieux comprendre
les décisions qui sont prises pour leur
bien aucune décision n'est prise
compteront évidemment pour leur bien
mais essayons de mieux le faire
comprendre et d'en avoir des résultats
jean-bernard la bile est ce que vous
vous avez entendu ça dans vos
rassemblement de gilet jaune depuis
quelques c'est à dire est ce que vous
avez entendu que les citoyens ne se
sentent pas compris par les politiques
ce n'est que emmanuel macron n'a pas
réussi à inverser les chinois et moi le
premier leader parce que je trouve que
tout ça me paraît quand même un peu
incohérent par exemple on nous demande
de faire des économies d'énergie c'est
tout juste si on ne culpabilise pas et
dans le même temps nous on a perdu au
village
pas là j'en ai perdu la poste les impôts
ap ap la banque
donc comment on fait on des disparitions
des services du commissaire à la ville
de magog alors quand on parle de
transition transition ça veut dire pour
moi ça implique quelque chose qui
s'inscrit dans une durée on est bien
d'accord et l'a brutalement on nous
annonce que on augmente une taxe je vois
pas ce que ça a à voir avec l'écologie
s'est fait sans accompagnement social
c'est irresponsable de faire grossir les
écologistes on n'a jamais été pour à
table et des personnes qui n'arrivent
pas à finir leurs fins je colle au gie
ça sert de bouc émissaire pour le texte
et une impression d'être un peu
effectivement les boucs émissaires mais
bon on n'est pas là pour le moment on en
est c'est la voie de la réconciliation
c'est d'arriver effectivement à de
nouveaux dialoguer mais il ya des
obstacles en communication il ya
toujours des erreurs
alors il ya des facteurs il ya des
facteurs sociologiques quand vous venez
de différents univers sociaux vous avez
du mal à échanger il ya des facteurs
intellectuelle parce que si vous vous
exprimez seulement en sigle en chiffres
en hausse avant comment voulez-vous mais
revenons sur la voie du coeur écoutons
nous parlons et là vous pouvez alors
faire surgir effectivement de nouveau
avant la réconciliation et à
l'apaisement
la colère on l'a tous traversé c'est un
sentiment universel je vous ai passé
traverser la colère dans votre vie c'est
vous avez pas vraiment vécu donc vous
vous dire les années des gouvernements
il faut retrouver l'apaisement pour
retrouver ensuite les voies du dialogue
petit à petit effectivement mais il va
falloir donner quelque chose c'est à
dire on parlait du smic lui et ses choix
mais quelque chose de fort on en parlait
le pragmatique aux audits qui sf la
suppression de l'sf c'est une erreur oui
est-ce qu'on ne le pense françois
hollande il va traîner ce boulet là
emmanuel macron pour l'ensemble de son
quinquennat lisf c'est que ça concerne
300 milles peut-être personnes en france
trente mille personnes à paris mais
c'est la trame seul homme mais oui
c'était important de le garder vous
pouvez pas d'un côté de retirer 5 euros
sur les apl retirer moi mes parents
m'ont dit emma et 50 euros sur nos
retraites
et puis dans notre côté supprime il y
est c'est fait elle vient de là
l'injustice parce qu'on voit certains
qu'ils reçoivent et d'autres qui paye
100 ans comment on fait pour retisser le
lien entre les français et les
politiques que que finalement tous les
représentants aient compris votre
mouvement ont un peu perdu quelque part
par moments dans ce qui est clair c'est
que vu la situation actuelle
il faut revenir aux fondamentaux
fondamentaux de la république de la
démocratie c'est-à-dire le gouvernement
du peuple par le peuple et pour le
peuple et le maquereau on l'a oublié
et c'est vrai qu'avec lui c'est un petit
peu le gouvernement d'une caste contre
le gouvernement de la rue c'est
d'ailleurs pour dire est abondée mon
propos il ya un excellent article du jdd
aujourd'hui notamment sur les donateurs
d'emmanuel macron qui montre qu'il ya
plus de 600 donateurs extrêmement riche
chiffres de l'agglomération parisienne
et des capitales étrangères
vous dites qu'il est temps d'arrêter les
français il est totalement déconnectée
des cônes et que sa majorité des
connectés ils n'entendent pas les
français
et ce problème ce mouvement social sans
précédent qui se lève c'est pas qu'un
problème d'argent
c'est pas qu'un problème il attend voit
rien n'est réglé sur ordinateur des ares
publie par ailleurs ce sera pas l'eau
une petite obole qui va contenter les
français le problème de fond c'est que
pendant des années en fait le peuple
français n'a pas été écoutés a été
méprisée et le peuple majorité encore
une fois et je pense qu'il faut pour
qu'ils se fassent entendre revoir
totalement nos institutions et faire en
sorte déjà que la retombée l'assemblée
nationale soit représentatif du peuple
français
il faut instaurer la proportionnelle
intégrale je vais parler à votre chien
qui dose de proportionnelle en projet
mais ça coince les doigts des français
côte et sera représenté à l'assemblée
nationale c'est essentiel il faut faire
la place aussi au référendum
d'initiative populaire comme c'était par
exemple de marine le pen là on arrive il
reste deux minutes d'émission ce concept
vous couvrir vous disiez paris c'est ce
que au delà de ce que vous avez déjà
envisagé la ce que vous proposez ce
matin il y a aussi des réformes plus
profondes et gilet jaune certains
demandent la dissolution de l'assemblée
nationale constituante et que sais-je
encore est-ce qu'il faut redonner la
parole au peuple
je pense qu'il faut il faut garder
l'esprit de démocratie la constitution
de 58 l'est pas il faut pas l'ajouter
comme ça je
très surpris parce que en tant que
parlementaire je reçois j'ai reçu trois
directives entre guillemets en termes de
directive est utilisé franchement mais
il y a tout et rien dedans mais il ya
des choses qui me font dresser les
cheveux sur la tête vous supprimez le
parlement supprimant de parlement
faisant de démocratie directe avec le
front national seraient très bien
supprimons supprimons a reçu mon tour je
veux dire il ya un moment il faut je
suis d'accord non mais c'est ce que j'ai
reçu à temps les pardonnez-moi trt j'ai
reçu j'ai reçu des indications de cette
nature reprenons calmement les choses
repositionnant faisons évoluer notre
système vous l'avez justement appelée
onu une réforme constitutionnelle en
cours
il faut la mener au bout il faudra
peut-être encore la modifier à
l'intérieur du texte on verra peut-être
jean-marie le mot de la fin il est pour
vous il va y avoir une quatrième
rencontre mais d'un mois parce qu'on est
vraiment on a signé une quatrième
journée de mobilisation nous penser
qu'il faut la faire à bas mot à titre
personnel aux magny jeu sinistrés voilà
c'est fait mais ça sera le mot de la fin
parce qu'on a on arrive au terme de
cette émission merci à tous d'avoir
accepté de participer et de débattre ce
matin en direct merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis dans un instant le point
sur l'actualité régionale avec marie
joly et la partie nationale de dimanche
en politique francis letellier reçoit
marine le pen la présidente du
rassemblement national bon dimanche à
tous sur france 3
[Musique]